La volta al món a peu, dia 272, avui és divendres 28 d'agost, i m'hi poso ben d'hora.
Són les 6 i poc.
Ostres, Enric, que bé, així evites les calorades del migdia.
Sí, però la veritat és que m'he posat d'hora perquè un gai m'ha despertat a les 5 del matí.
I no ha parat.
Pa, pa, pa, saps el típic despertador que li dones però segueix sonant?
Doncs això era el gai.
Bueno, tu, està bé, està bé, he dormit bé.
I ja està, molta tranquil·litat al jardí d'aquest home.
Matí plaç, si encara no ha sortit el sol, aquí a Afganistan, let's go!
Les 9 i 9, ja, 14 quilòmetres, molt bé.
I aquí davant tenim un altre túnel, l'he gravat des de lluny perquè des de prop, no sé, que n'hi hagi militars també.
Ahir, l'home aquest que ens vam comunicar així més o menys de la casa,
em va dir que aquest túnel, bueno, em va dir,
vaig entendre que aquest túnel estava obert fins a les 12.
No sé, dubto molt jo que pugui passar per aquest túnel.
Però home, tu, estaria bastant bé.
Si no, també he de fer un rodeo que no és tan gran com el d'ahir, però també és rodeo.
Ja és l'últim, eh, de tota aquesta sèrie de dies caminant per aquí a la vora, l'últim túnel.
A veure si tenim sort.
Era d'esperar, el militar no m'ha deixat passar i ja veig els camions que passen per aquí
i, igual que l'altre desviamenta,
doncs tampoc està pavimentat.
Són gairebé 10 quilòmetres, unes bones dues hores,
fins al proper supermercat on descansaré.
Encara que, bueno, des que he començat no he descansat.
Sóc per aquí dues hores.
Sí que dubto molt que tiri dues hores sense parar un moment, eh.
Jo crec que ara que trobi un ombre, m'assec.
Doncs ja està, altra banda del túnel.
Sí, sí.
Està molt tancat.
Bueno, calor intensa, són...
No són ni les 11.
Calor ja intensa i tinc l'aigua ja calenta, però sopa, eh, sopa.
Ara d'aquí 4 quilòmetres, què es diu, ràpid, ja en t'hauria un súper.
I mira, l'únic que necessito és beguda freda, eh, i una ombra.
Mira, un altre súper bloc.
Perillós, eh, aquesta carretera.
Imagina't que et cau això sobre la terra.
Mentre estàs per aquí.
Va!
Uf!
Ja m'he hidratat.
Bueno, tu, una de les notícies, hi ha un restaurant.
Són les 12.
Però bueno, sí, passaré perquè crec que ja no n'hi ha més en tot el dia, eh.
Vaig a... a veure si em donen...
Avui em ve de gust el oix, el plof.
A veure si tenen.
Mira, tenien sopa, però no em venia de gust la sopa.
No m'agraden molt les sopes d'aquest país.
I els he dit, us transfereu plof, oix,
i diu...
Sí, però t'has d'esperar 30 minuts.
Al final ha sigut una hora d'espera.
Però aquí ho tinc.
Aquí ho tinc, em venia més de gust això que la sopa, tu.
Tres trossos de carn, trist, però sí.
Bueno, tu, avui he caminat molt i encara és d'hora una i 25.
Ja porto 25 quilòmetres, tu.
Bueno, dues hores i pico més tard, torno a caminar.
La cacau, eh.
Hem tornat a aplicar la clema solar.
Clema solar, la crema solar.
Perquè s'ha d'aplicar en teoria cada tres hores.
Més o menys, ho segueixo bastant.
I me'n poso també a la cara, encara que tingui el barret i no m'estigui donant,
me'n poso igualment.
I després als braços i a les cames.
Doncs també, el que passa és que no me'n poso per totes les cames, no.
Potser ho hauria de fer, però no ho faig.
Poso com a molt una mica els genolls o una mica a darrere,
en cas que el sol toqui de costat o de darrere, depèn de com vagi.
Bueno, he vist un lloc per acampar.
He vist un lloc per acampar a 19 quilòmetres.
Sí, ja.
Són les dues i mitja i estic plantejant el lloc d'acampar.
19 quilòmetres és possible.
Però, bueno, és tirar parant molt poc, eh.
Ho intentaré, a veure.
Ara mateix, un lloc bastant brutal,
en aquesta vall tan angosta.
Gaudint d'aquesta carretera tan ben feta,
però m'ha dit un ciclista que, a partir de demà,
deixa d'estar tan ben pavimentada
i ja passa a ser pista de grava durant els següents, no sé,
cent i pico, 200 quilòmetres.
Bueno, anar pel Pamir, anar per on estic anant,
és tota una aventura, però anar pel costat afganès,
això sí que seria una aventura brutal, eh.
Mireu com és la pista.
Bueno, és que no sé si ni m'agrada.
Bueno, és que no sé si ni cap un cotxe aquí, eh.
Suposo que sí, però molt, molt justet, eh.
I has d'anar amb els d'això aquí dalt, eh.
Molt heavy.
Això sí que seria una aventura, fer tota aquesta part de la frontera afganesa.
He de dir que avui no he parlat gaire d'Afganistan
perquè no he vist gaire activitat a l'altra banda de la frontera.
Algun poble, alguna persona menjant-se, però no...
Sembla un safari, això, eh.
Sí, sí, sembla un safari perquè tens aquí les tanques
i tu vas mirant a la gent de l'altra banda què fa i tal,
com si fossin animalons.
La 6 i mitja, 46 quilòmetres.
Encara no he campat perquè necessito aigua.
Estic entrant a una vila i aquí hi ha una benzinera,
aquí just davant meu.
Tentaré comprar aigua
i hi ha un parell de llocs a l'aplicació aquesta que em diu que...
Bé, que potser es pot acampar.
Però el primer, el primer, aigua.
Val, dos litres d'aigua aconseguida
i l'aplicació indica que cap aquí, potser en aquest camí,
hi ha un... un lloc.
Diu que a algunes persones que han vingut aquí
algú els ha vingut a demanar-los diners
per cobrar-los per passar la nit.
I les quantitats varien.
Són gent que potser s'aprofita una mica.
També hi ha gent que diu que no els han demanat res.
Bé, el fet de jo venir just a aquesta hora,
que falten 10 minuts per la posta de sol,
és un molt bon lloc, eh?
Jo crec que redueix les possibilitats que em demanin res.
Mireu, mireu.
Jo, avui en tot el dia,
no havia vist un lloc així.
Pla.
Veig alguns joves allà a la carretera,
que si em veuen em poden venir a tocar la pera.
Crec que ja m'estan veient.
Però bé, aquí està molt bé.
Ara falta escollir el lloc.
Allà estaria més protegit de les mirades,
però més polsagós.
I aquí, entre els arbres, doncs, estic més amagat
i sempre entre els arbres és més maco.
Hi ha d'orillo, eh, avui?
Però he de dir que,
degut a l'orografia del terreny
i degut a que m'he aixecat bastant d'hora,
avui he tingut menys impacte de sol,
menys insolació.
I home, això està molt bé.
Vinga, va, vaig a escollir el lloc.
Bueno, a veure, el camp és gran,
però just al lloc on marcava l'aplicació
hi havia l'home amb les seves vaques,
cosa que advertia l'aplicació.
Però per això no m'he volgut apropar allà.
I ara, hi havia una review que deia que
un tio no li va molar molt el lloc
i va pujar una mica més dalt,
al costat de la subestació, que és aquesta,
i va estar més tranquil.
I crec que m'agrada la idea.
Això sí, fa una mica de vent avui, eh?
No és ben alarmant, però clar,
molesta una mica de cara a dormir,
perquè si fa sol i la tenda...
Parlo molt lent, eh?
Perquè estic cansat.
Bueno, vaig a mirar, també.
Vale, vale. Aquí molt millor, eh?
Sí, sí, aquí no mira ningú.
Tinc més camps, em puc posar per aquí mateix.
Aquí tinc la subestació.
Bueno, una cama ja hi haurà, però...
no passa res.
Sí, sí, sí, sí, tu.
Molt millor, molt millor.
Bueno, a veure, que han passat un parell de coses.
En primer lloc, com fa una mica de vent,
no gaire, ara ha baixat,
he decidit instal·lar els vents.
Si us en recordeu, vaig comprar a Georgia
uns vents, bueno, un cordino,
i 4 piquetes, encara no les havia posat
perquè no havia calgut,
perquè pel Pamir, més endavant,
pel Pamir d'aquí un parell de setmanes o una setmana,
començarà a fer una mica més vent, crec,
i volia reforçar la tenda, no?
Doncs bé, he fet un...
un lup normal amb un llaç
perquè pugui ser fàcil de treure aquí dalt, als pals,
al lloc on té la tenda per instal·lar els vents,
i després he fet un nus que es diu...
bueno, ara us ho poso aquí a pantalla,
no recordo el nom,
és un nus que està bé pels vents.
Espereu, que fico tensalació de soroll.
Està bé pels vents perquè es pot tensar.
Com podeu veure, estic... he tensat els vents.
Només n'he posat dos perquè, bueno, es feia fosc, tal,
i de fet el vent ve d'allà, no?
Llavors m'interessa que...
que la tenda, doncs, estigui reforçada d'aquella banda.
Bueno, de moment...
de moment sembla que...
que funciona.
Val, i després m'he passat una aigua,
m'he fet una dutxa,
i quan ja havia acabat,
i m'acabava de posar la samarreta
i estava netejant-me els peus,
ve un home.
Sí.
Allò que qui pensava que estava tan...
tan amagat.
I ve un home, i junt amb l'home, que em saluda,
ei, apareix una vaca que comença a córrer cap a mi.
I jo, ai, ai, ai.
Records de la via alpina.
Espereu.
I bueno, doncs, el tio es fica entremig,
perquè hi ha les seves vaques,
el tio es fica entremig i la vaca para i ja està.
I bueno, clar, no parlava anglès, vale?
No ens hem pogut comunicar gairebé.
M'ha intentat parlar,
teníem una vista, no he pogut escriure amb el traductor,
perquè parlant no funcionava,
perquè hi ha poca cobertura, tal.
Però bueno,
jo he entès el següent.
He entès que puc acampar aquí,
no m'ha demanat diners,
que no hi ha cap problema,
però que hi ha dues vaques
que estaran donant voltes tota la nit per aquí.
Ara no sé on són,
si no us faria una mica de vídeo.
Abans estava per aquí,
ara suposo que has anat.
No m'atropellaran.
No m'atropellaran,
però estaran donant moltes per aquí.
Espero,
espero que no estiguin molt a prop
i comencin a curiosejar.
Si són dos, només les puc espantar, saps?
Si són com a Suïssa, que em va passar,
que són 30 vaques,
llavors allà tenim un problema, no?
Però si són dos, bueno, no sé.
Ei, és que et no veig.
Hi ha una vaca aquí?
Sí, sí, aquí hi ha la vaca.
Camina molt ràpid, eh?
No sé, una mica sospitós.
Ai, ai, ai,
que tindrem nit mogudet.
N'hi ha més de dos, eh?
El teu n'ha fet dos, però
n'hi ha més de dos, eh?
Bueno.
Bueno, ai, ai, ai.
Llavors,
doncs això, que en principi em quedo aquí.
Si passa alguna cosa durant la nit,
el dia següent, el dia següent.
47 km avui,
bastant,
bastant, bastant,
i tres refrescs de diners
gastats, diria que
10 euros,
i
he parlat amb un ciclista,
amb aquest home
d'aquí, i
i ja està, diria que ja està.
Cafè és cap.
Bueno, un dia,
un dia més, un dia més, sincerament.
He de dir que
Tadjikistan és un país que sí que és una aventura,
però
no sé si l'estic acabant de gaudir, eh?
Hi ha moments que sí que gaudeixo, dic, buah, estic aquí,
no sé què, però costa, costa.
I he d'admetre que cada dia
miro quan queda
per acabar el país.
També perquè no tinc molta cosa a fer, no?
Hi ha molt d'internet, a vegades estic ara sense cobertura,
i em poso a mirar quan queda, no?
Però sí, cada dia ho faig,
i això crec que no ho havia fet a cap altre país, eh?
Ai, ai, ai,
aquesta nit. Bona nit!